yeah yeah how many people have you
killed what do you think in your life on
purpose I don't on purpose like well I I
really feel bad about all the insects
I've killed in my life
insects yeah yeah I look back and I'm
like I didn't need to kill those spiders
you're stomping things like I hate I
hate all that now the other day I this
is a true story I reached peak vegan the
other day there was a house centipede
drowning in my bathtub when I was taking
a shower
you know how centipede like the grossest
bug ever and I I was like I gotta save
it because if I if I think I'm if I love
every creature got to save this thing
why would I like force it to drown so I
went and I got a paper towel I was so
scared I used to have the biggest phobia
of these things so the fact that was
picking it up I was like really proud of
myself and I was like I'm gonna like
damp it off and like get it clean and I
pulled back the paper towel and I'm
really scared I was like naked and naked
and afraid and I'm like and it was a
clump of pubes that I had fully
oh yeah it was like a lock it was locked
how many legs
[Music]
Kevin Nealon is here it's a big deal I
was saying yesterday I can't believe I'm
like friends with you there are certain
people you become friends with in this
business and you just like you never
could have predicted it and never could
have and I'm honestly I feel friends
with you we went hiking the other day we
did I did your show hiking with kevin
judah friedlander you need to do that
show do you like I can hike you can hike
Flatliner do you flat line hike flat
lining flat trail okay it's my planet it
earth planet is if some hikers Nicki
seem like they're Flatliners I think you
know cup of coffee is there hiking or
Canada a coke yeah no and that's cool
that's they just want to kind of just
take it easy yeah just walk walk where
do you go we went hiking up in tree
people up in top of Fryman Canyon yes
that's right yeah it was a Los Angeles
so you I went hiking with Kevin he
doesn't interview it's on his Instagram
it's also on his YouTube but what's your
YouTube channel it's um youtube.com
forward slash Kevin Nealon comedy or
hashtag hiking with Kevin hiking with
Kevin you can find he interviews
different celebrities on a hike and it's
all done by him I mean he could have
another camera there following there
could be other stuff but it's him with a
selfie stick interviewing you it's a
dream in a drone now he's got a drone
shot I watched Kevin Nealon struggle
with a drone for about 40 minutes until
we got the shot but we got the shot we
got the shot until it crashed into the
car yet did crash into a tree but it
looks the shot you got to see it we're
coming down the hillside and we had so
much rain the hill set is so green it
looks like the beginning of the sound of
music yes down the path yeah I'm so
excited to see it so that'll be out soon
but yeah you have you have so many great
people on that show and you um how did
that show come about well I was friends
with Matthew Modine still him from Full
Metal Jacket you know and and I called
him one day about two years ago same
anyone go for a hike up in the canyon
near my house he goes sure he lives in
Venice you know not too far from me so
we meet and we're hiking and it's you
know it's pretty rugged hike and up
we're up near the top and it's steep and
we're both out of breath and I thought
of a funny bit where I'm in here
were so out of breath we can't
understand either one of us I was just
holding my camera like that you know
videotaping and that was funny and then
on the way down on the backside I
interviewed him some more I said Matt
you ever turned down any like movies
that you regret and he rolled his eyes
oh my god after Full Metal Jacket I was
just so picky I turned down the Michael
J Fox rolling back to the future
I turned down the Tom Hanks role and big
Charlie Sheen role in Wall Street and
let's see Tom Cruise role in Top Gun
I said you idiot and we both laughed and
I posted on Instagram and Twitter and I
just type with somebody different every
week and then Stern liked it you know
yeah because you should make it longer
and I so I started a YouTube channel yes
and and hasn't been fulfilling every
Thursday I post a hike yeah and I
started creating the season so I'm in my
second season now and the first season I
did 31 hikes God and this one I'm
already into the 20s I think who's the
best hiker of everyone you really you
were the best because first of all
you're so prompt Thank You Judah great
shape thank you were so flexible and
you're so accommodating and you were so
conversational thank you you were just
so good and you were patient when I was
trying to do the drone I just enjoy
hanging out with Kevin Nealon I mean
that was kind of what I was in it for
and then you gave me a bag of swag that
I actually loved I was just saying you
know I don't love bags of swag anymore
and I don't want them but I really love
that you give me a hat and a cool
backpack and a shirt that I've been
wearing that says hiking with Kevin
really Warren you gave me two vegan bars
not even knowing that they were vegan
probably and I know that you like a
certain kind of protein bars oh my god
Kevin it was it was awesome so I didn't
even know I was gonna in a 50-dollar
start Starbucks card how dare I forget
that was the best yeah I will never turn
down a Starbucks card that was that was
awesome DJ what do you like at Starbucks
a venti extra hot Oh
milk visto with sprinkle of powder and
five stevia how many times you have to
repeat that to the barista I don't
repeat it I order it on my mobile order
so it's not to anyone with me having to
say it if you're not doing the mobile
order Judah do you drink Starbucks I
don't drink coffee you don't I don't do
caffeine or any other long has that been
going on legal or illegal no drugs
yeah no caffeine your whole life
straightedge have you ever done it I've
done caffeine a couple times oh okay
yeah no no but just you know understand
always had a friend with me my problem
is sha'ban oh yeah I can't see my
problem is I don't mine is very
impulsive when I will buy a Starbucks
ago oh do I feel like coffee yeah I'll
go in so I don't have time to like
pre-order it yeah you're a normal person
I typically just get a regular coffee
but I like it hot like a lawsuit hot I
love it lawsuit hot I need it so hot
it's um that's why I order an extra hot
I take it hot because I chug everything
and it's the only way for me to slow
down
chug life I really do I'm a fast person
here's what you need to get I just
recently found out about these coffee
cups that keep it hot for a long time
okay yes I don't even think I need ice
you can have a sip in the morning and
then come back to it two o'clock in the
afternoon and it's still hot anything
Kevin it is if I start a coffee it will
be done I clean my plate every time I
start a meal like I don't leave me I
don't take my time with things I rush
things
you have indigestion alot no no you have
a good system I just remember I came
over to the kid being like I talk fast I
move fast I everything I really do
everything when you go when are you like
totally besides sleeping this shut down
and relaxed you ever did I sit and when
I meditate but that's kind of forced
yeah who else do you guys just sit and
do like I said on my phone you know but
I mean I'm fast on the phone you know
double-double thumber oh that would be
no are you yeah
you can flip it sideways yeah thumbs not
all the time but one thumb sometimes it
sometimes two thumbs sometimes I got all
10 fingers going on it
no big as your phone it's a really tiny
phone oh yeah it's a microchip phone IQ
in my mouth just good technique yeah I
would think you I don't mean I don't
have hobbies do you guys have don't have
a ha no no I don't and I need to get
some dip no that'll slow you down that
would slow me down I just don't like I
don't like that feeling of I know what
your hobby yarn that's Instagram
yeah that's your hobby yeah that's not a
hobby that doesn't count you have to
kill a zombie IQ read sometimes you
don't like to sit down and read a good
mystery no you get therapy
I used to why why did you let that go
was that a hobby that felt like a I let
it go because I had a really bad
therapist and then I had a therapist
that I just felt like oh this is about
as good as having a conversation with
one of my smart friends like it just why
am i paying for this person to give me
exactly what all my intellectual friends
give me why were you going to therapy
um because I want to be a better person
I want to be happy I want to be in a
relationship and I want I want to stop
needing things and I want to feel good
about myself what's your hobby is hiking
now because now that's the part of your
job when can I stop talking about
hobbies I have so many hobbies I love to
sketch you know it's true put
caricatures on my Instagram Kevin Nealon
artwork I did drawing - yeah you do it's
so that's dirt in itself I like to play
I play the five string banjo and the
guitar and I'm learning how to play the
piano now I love playing the piano I'm
not even that good but I'm learning the
scales and chords and stuff cuz do you
get this panel is everywhere and so many
people play the piano I think it must be
easy yeah I know people to play the
piano a lot and it doesn't seem easy it
is once you get the idea of one end yeah
both hands doing two different things at
the same time you're a double
so I've tried to play guitar so many
times would you be a great guitar player
and not look good playing again so I
look so cool I mean I can play like I
know chords but my I have no rhythm I
can do all the fingering you did Dancing
with the Stars yeah and I got first
voted off oh I thought you won I know
but you seem like you would be a good
club dancer though no no but you're
athletic I've seen you one night nope I
can run a warrior and I got less on that
too first I really did that you're not
afraid to do anything you're not afraid
to fail and good at running I'm good at
hiking but there's no running with the
Stars and others hiking with the stars
realize that just really is what I love
about you you are open to do anything
because you are you want to explore and
you want to experience things you do it
all what have you turned down lately
I've turned down quite a lot no nothing
you'll take anything don't reverse for
that like you know I always heard Joan
Rivers did anything and I did a rap
battle show like I'll just I'll do stuff
that it's called drop the mic it's on
TBS oh yeah okay it's fun it was fun it
was Brad Williams little person yeah
so you do your open doing the I think if
I had a show where I dragged people
along the street like on there with
their jacket just drag them along for
like three blocks you go premiere
episode I'll sign me up I wouldn't have
to do anything and I could like look bad
like a lot of doing these things is like
you want to look good and it's
exhausting for me to do hair and makeup
I feel like if I was on the show where
I'm being dragged in the street by my
jacket
you should look a little disheveled but
you came on my hike and you were like
perfect
you looked perfect I mean have you seen
her like okay I mean in shape talks I am
going to my legs now because I used to
hate my legs my whole life and now I'm
like you know what I I'm just gonna like
them because get them insured please for
me will you please
Kevin oh my god I'm serious at least the
right leg I mean so what do you do for
hobbies Judah draw draw sometimes read
ping-pong I play playing later today
I'll play you anytime I'll play thank
you to the cleaners I'll play it okay I
have my paddle with me right I have my
table with me
great I have my net there's actually
this one ping-pong place it's a it's
like a rec center and Queen does that
susan sarandon plays the one I'm going
to today is yes okay but there's one
place there's one place in Queens it's
it's like a rec center why kind of a
place and from like I think from like
six to nine or something at night they
have ping-pong and it's really
competitive there and there's a lot of
regulars and so if you don't get that
right at the beginning you're you could
wait an hour to play so so one time Mike
so the first time I got there I couldn't
even get in because there's so many
people and the second time I got there
early and and I had a table and then I
realized that the venue they provide the
tables but they don't provide the nets
and then everyone's looking at me like
I'm the biggest idiot they're like you
didn't bring your own net and I'm like
no I usually don't bring a net yeah so I
do that without gonna play again so
[Laughter]
sweet man I don't want to brag but in
college I was on the table tennis team
and we played Yale and schools like that
Wow known for having one of the weaker
table tennis now this is back in the
1900s oh yeah yeah well then maybe do
you have a sandpaper paddle or is it the
thigh do it's in storage though I'm in
the middle of trying to get you what do
you call it
that's fine anything you want yeah
normal thing to call it is there a cool
word for have you ever watched on
YouTube
cable tennis like the pros oh cool it
amazing the way they they return the
ball like from 30 feet away from the
table and I saw Forrest Gump I get it
that was that was fake I know but I know
that people can do what he did
yeah they can but play against a wall by
themselves no just be so fast oh yeah I
played this wall one time it was so good
I couldn't hit anything back what are
your hobbies I like pink I shoot pool
that's our shoot pools great yeah that's
really relaxing yeah it is yeah I like
shootin pool I ride a bicycle
a color I don't draw you have a coloring
book how often do you color I mean is
this a real thing that I don't to go to
week's is relaxing what kind of Krantz
you work with Crayolas I got Crayolas
trailers are the best
something the Triad
world has expanded so much Brandi go
back to the Krantz Fuhrman do you ever
stripped the paper off and just hold it
bare in your hand I have that's the best
contact not for years yeah I love it man
do you color really give it a color if
my son was like you know yeah I be I
really outshine him yes I wouldn't go
outside the line at all I would keep it
inside the line
do you really know do you bring your own
lines but we didn't finish my hobbies
okay let's get back to them okay let's
recap then because I don't have any okay
let's recap and maybe you might enjoy
some of these and you might want to do
banjo banjo guitar sketching drawing
painting you do great sketches can we
talk about your sketches for a second
you do like caricatures of people it's
almost caricature like sketching yeah
its caricatures yeah wait what makes
something a character as opposed to like
I'm trying to make this look like a
person it's just a drawing of a person
characters you accentuate their features
you exaggerate you bully them with when
I got I got a caricature John of me when
I was like 11 and there's a picture of
me sitting on
this on this picnic table like with this
art you know Art Fair something and I'm
sitting across from this guy who said to
me and I am so excited all the
attentions on me like this is like
fulfilling every need I needed as a like
there's gonna be a piece of art made
with my image on it like it couldn't be
cooler like what and I'm sitting there
and I'm like I am famous this is awesome
and you can see me I'm just like smiling
like so excited and I it was the last
moment of my innocence because it was
broken seconds later when he handed it
to me and I had such severe buck teeth
he made me a rabbit that was like
rollerblading or whatever you know
you're like I like that and they throw
it and I did not know that I had buck
teeth everyone yeah yeah and I was
called like that was pretty are you
Freddie Mercury for Halloween I should
have been my parents should have been on
that but I just like you know I was I
just had my teeth are as big as their
now my head was very small and they just
stuck out and everyone called me about
tooth Weaver you know one time I was in
you get it again oh yeah I had Chiclets
hanging out of my mouth yeah we both
were buck tooth well you grew into your
teeth we did so you'll do this to people
on planes like you'll you'll post a
picture that you have or a sketch that
you've done of like a caricature of
someone that you're kind of observing on
the plane
do they ever find out that has anyone
ever seen themselves in your Instagram
no not that I know of sleeping if it's a
long flight I want to be in a flight
with you someday and I'd love to sketch
you sometime even not on a flight will
you leave my teeth alone you have great
teeth I do now really interesting
because you don't have veneers and you
don't like the perfect Smile okay no
perfectly it's perfectly imperfect thing
great well I did get Invisalign to fix
it and it didn't really fix it so I was
perfectly straight teeth but you have
like teeth I think are such they're so
identifying with people yes and
literally like if you're in a burn
accident there's only identifying thing
I mean don't you think don't you think
it's easier
if you're gonna kill somebody yeah you
know they'll identify the mother teeth
yeah go to the dentist's office get
their files and burn them so they
compare them with the burn I'm
remembering a joke that you made me
really laugh that you said I think I
heard it a couple of years ago I don't
know how you made your girlfriend I
don't know you met your girlfriend on
Google Earth yeah yeah she thought they
works great for me she had been she had
been stalking me for years
Judah had some speaking of like a Kevin
Nealon here who has inspired me so much
communiclique Judah as well I remember
seeing Judah in 2005 I took a trip with
my best friend to New York I just
started doing comedy like open mics like
I wasn't in the Midwest and we came here
and we went to the Comedy Cellar and I
still remember you talking about going
fishing and what did you catch oh yeah
that I caught a whale when I cut it open
there were about 14 tarpon inside mostly
100 to 200 pound range but I'm glad you
other people of you know had your little
fishing trips and feel good about
yourself you're just so smart and your
comedy is so funny it's just really I
mean you know you see him at first you
think oh this guy might be crazy you
know but he gets on stage and it's so
clever and funny and no you're right
about to die like I think I as everyone
we judge people based on yeah I judged
him based on his comedy and was just
like so intimidated by him I never
wanted to like even attempt to be
friends with him and everyone says this
about Judah and I'm trying to tell
people how I feel about them before it's
too late
not that any but you know because with
Brody and stuff I'm like I wish I would
have let Brody know I wish I would have
let you know yeah but Jude what Judah
means to me is like he is so he's
someone and this is rare with comedians
they really wanna they ask good
questions they're interested in you he's
agree he's just he's someone who always
I'm excited to see because you actually
care about other people and you're not
only like so funny and definitely care
about yourself enough to be so fun like
you have to be
somewhat of a narcissist but for some
reason you're actually like a really
good friend and you care about people I
just want to say that we love you I mean
it's time someone dies we all go why did
I tell them before and it's not that I
think any of one's gonna die but it's
like why not just spread that why not
tell people how you feel
did I can I just say one day because
it's not my mind um Tom Davis was a
writer on Saturday Night Live he was
partners with Al Franken yeah
Al Franken wrote a book he tell us about
this and he says that Tom Davis came
down with a terminal illness and he only
was given like a few months to live
so I think Lauren Michaels threw a party
for him and a lot of people came and
they were just it was like you know to
pay your respects to him when he's alive
and yeah give him your love and
everybody made speeches and they loved
him and and that was a very nice thing
and they said goodbye to him well he
lasted longer than he thought it was
gonna last and he was embarrassed to
come out and see these people because
are you still alive yes I am I'm sorry
I'm sorry and he kept living until
eventually he did pass away but it was
really uncomfortable for him he was
embarrassed that he was alive still
that's so funny
that's I mean yeah Franken and Davis
they were calm yeah well that's gotta be
the way you feel when you get married
and then you get divorced like really
soon after you know some couples like I
know a couple that just got married and
got divorced before a year before the
warrantees were up on the blenders and
it's just so that's gotta be the same
kind of feeling or what if you get
married again and you invite the same
people and they do we gotta get them
another gift do you I don't know you've
been married twice
what's your all's taken the second time
I didn't have him really a wedding we
went to Italy and got married just
haven't heard me great what's your take
on destination weddings what's your take
I did one and um in Italy and Lake Como
and was it you said it was was it a big
wedding or a small it was just me and
her yeah we had to pay Oh two Italian
sub witnessin okay but what about what
you'd it's a destination wedding and
you're having a
wedding and inviting tons of people then
you gotta fly them in absolutely fly
them in like it's good excuse for a fun
time but what if they don't fly you they
just expect you to then you hope the
marriage doesn't divorced oh really
there's actually a statistic that just
came out that said the more money you
spend which completely makes sense that
means you're kind of like a
materialistic we're doing it for the
event it makes sense that there's not
like a real connection today the
statistic on the size of the engagement
rings - probably around it's probably
the same kind of Nicki did I tell you
when when I went to Lake Como to get
married in Bellagio yeah at the Bellagio
there's a place called Bellagio actually
named after the casino go on I mean it's
it's in the town hall and the mayor's
marrying us it's all in Italian maybe I
don't even know if we got married me was
a restraining order but but I look
outside and all these paparazzi are
forming outside in the courtyard and I'm
thinking oh no what's going on you know
nobody knows we're getting married and
even if they did they wouldn't be like
this and there's like probably 50
paparazzi out there with cameras and
everything and I come outside and they
take pictures and stuff and they follow
us down the walkway and I found out that
they thought I was Matt Damon because
Matt Damon had had been looking at it
like eight weeks earlier for a place to
get married or a couple months earlier
and they thought he was coming back they
hurt an American celebrity was coming to
get married so they thought it was Matt
Damon so the whole walk back I'm saying
I'm not Matt Damon no Matt Damon and
they kept taking pictures and the next
day we're seeing at the cafe by the lake
and there's somebody reading the Italian
newspaper next to us and it's a picture
of me my wife on the front and above it
says non Adam Matt Damon that's amazing
oh that's so good yeah that was oh my
god I would look I mean that is a dress
worth to get married and have the
paparazzi want a picture of it in Italy
they say your hobby or you like
attention
I do that is your house I do like
attention I thought it's it's a problem
I think that Kathy Griffin's like that
too I think yeah yeah I know we have a
problem you and Kathy Griffin have a lot
like well I loved her reality show my
life on the d-list and that's exactly
what I want to do now is like I just
want to live my life and have cameras
follow me around like I beef totally
okay with that I would actually be more
than okay with it I actually actively
wanted change I think I am I am do you
mind people staring at you I don't like
that I I don't like if I wouldn't how
many cameras do you like to perform on
stage so I think you mind a camera from
the back only yes because my butt is so
disappointing I would I would mind that
I want to keep it front really yeah I'm
thinking about getting butt injections
I'm gonna be completely honest with
everyone here dude when you go into a
dressing room to try and close and they
have the three mirrors behind you young
are you kind of way you've never been no
I think no I think I think I've never
been in a bathroom I think I had to get
a suit a couple times so I saw those
okay okay yeah they're devastating yeah
you're thinking who's that person I know
that's my bud I like it was a suit it
wasn't like you know it's kind of loose
it's not exactly you know the suit
wasn't form-fitting so I can you don't
like those suits they were now they look
like pee-wee Herman suits all the tight
ones yeah short and tight yeah you look
like a tall guy yeah yeah why it's like
a it's like pee-wee Herman isn't it I
guess it's just like looks fashionable
and so it looks like who makes up these
ideas of fashion what that should be I
don't know I don't know I don't know I I
have heard recently that and there's
just nothing new in fact like fashion
has just done like they've done
literally everything everyone hold on to
whatever 90s clothes you're wearing now
because no kind of style it's gonna be
back in 20 years just just hold onto it
now don't go buy new stuff how about
balloon pants there they go Oh like the
UM MC Hammer hammer yeah yeah I don't
know those those are back yet
fashion is exhausting you know what an
industry though to make money in I know
and I just read some just statistics
about fast fashion you know just like
clothing is clothing contributes to more
pollution in the air making clothing
then every plane every ship every every
car for any kind of shipping and
handling that is happening in the world
it creates more pollution than all of
that I always do more clouds jerks
I see no rings on you no bracelets or
anything no what does this mean to you
it means that you're gonna make somebody
very happy once I'm low maintenance yes
you're very independent you're not needy
maybe I'm needy but you're independent
is attention i I am I can be very needy
yeah like I feel like I can't wear
contacts um no I mean yes sometimes you
have them in no no that'd be weird I'm
wearing glasses I know but I just write
about this woman who got LASIK in
November blind she it made her blind and
she it's really tragic she killed
herself in December because from LASIK I
just
I almost got LASIK in July I had the
appointment made and then the day before
the New York Times put out an article
about people who have really bad
reactions to LASIK that no one's talking
about everyone's just like it's so easy
this cut your eye open and then you're
fine
and it's 1% of people though have really
really bad side effects that's not
nothing 1% is something you could be
that 1% take it from me who thought I
wouldn't be voted off first of Dancing
with the Stars it's like someone has to
be have a 1 in 13 chance it's gonna be
someone I literally thought no one could
be no there's a 1% chance one in a
hundred there's you're gonna screw up
your eyes
so I cancelled the thing and then I read
this story about this woman it's a lot
of people they go blind I will tell you
that and maybe Judi you've experienced
this I had LASIK on my nipple ok nothing
no side effects at all
clear clear are you near nipple or far
nibbled far nipple now but I wasn't your
nipple got it got it got it what about
you do that you are
a lot of what Kevin just said yeah a lot
of lay sick
I don't want to talk about it well right
okay I didn't go well yeah yeah I'm you
bring it up though I'm sorry I didn't
realize that was such a sore spot for
you you know it still it's just after
lasik it shouldn't be sore though
[Music]
you